fondue it's this thing we do with cheese
we melt it we dip it we eat it in the
70s it became super popular but that
didn't just happen by chance there was
an ominous force behind it a real life
cheese cartel
a hundred years ago cheese was a hot
commodity in switzerland it was exported
at high volumes and played a major role
in the swiss economy but that all
changed after world war one european
countries devastated by the war could no
longer afford to buy expensive imported
cheese which was bad news for
switzerland so the government stepped in
and they formed the cheese union
basically it was a cartel and it worked
like this
the first thing they did was force every
dairy farmer and cheese monger to fix
the price of cheese eliminating
competition meaning everyone could stay
in the game the cheese cartel also told
them exactly how much cheese to make and
limited the varieties so instead of
making thousands of different kinds of
cheese they only made seven and it
worked the cartel controlled the cheese
supply for decades
by the 70s they got greedy and wanted to
expand their cheese racket globally so
they introduced the world to a dish
already popular in the freezing cold
alps fondue
by marketing cheese for fondue the
cartel was able to sell more i mean
think about it it takes a lot and i mean
a lot of cheese to fill a pot but as
with most cartels things got shady money
went missing people went to jail and by
the 1990s the swiss cheese union was
dismantled so there you have it the
reason we know and love fondue is
because of a shady government program
that convinced the world to consume
massive amounts of melted cheese
you